let's jump into this first story we'll
kick back off where we just were with
these with these hedge funds
check this story out this is amazing i i
almost i want to get a standing ovation
to the gamestop the amc the the
the meme stock apes is incredible you've
taken out a hedge fund
look at the cnet reports hedge fund that
bet against gamestop is closing down
it's game over for white scare white
square capital
it managed 440 million assets
at its peak it sent a letter to
investors selling plans to close down
the main fund
this month and return investor capital
following a review of the business model
according to the report
they they're announcing a double-digit
percentage
loss suffered by the first meme stock
rally in january
and oh boy it's only just begun so now
what you have is
and correct me if i'm wrong steve you
have a lot of these big hedge funds
that they they manipulate the game they
they they
it's it's a manipulated casino it's a
rigged game they can short a company
then their friends in the media say oh
this company's bad and it's going to
crash you better sell now
causing the stock price to plummet and
then the short sellers make off like
bandits
stripping and manipulating all of us so
what happens is
these uh these memestock apes are like
so these people have no choice but to
buy stocks
you know what to cover their shorts yes
so that means if we all buy them right
now and the price goes up they're forced
to buy them from us yes
let's play now hedge funds just imploded
can they alternately declare bankruptcy
and just wash the debt
the hedge funds they're leveraged here's
the problem here's the here's the issue
remember the deplorables are the common
mans on both sides of the trade
you have the ape army that is just a
collection of several million of people
throwing in
money and and by buying and holding
these traditional companies okay
and the stock price goes up because they
refuse to sell the shorts that are the
naked shorts
all that money they're managing is
essentially pension fund money
and what they're doing is they're using
and and they're doing this naked shorts
and using leverage to really not just
destroy the companies but to
speculate this is this is this is not
hedging is a natural part of wall street
to hedge certain long positions this is
not that
this is where you're in high speculation
to basically make a profit on destroying
companies and leaking information here's
where the rig game is
last summer steve cortez who's the great
guy over at newsmax and a trader for 30
years
he saw these meme stocks and last year
he does thousands of trades a year he
tried to buy
gamestop right first time his life not
not
margin but in a an online account he had
cash money in
first time in 30 years on wall street he
couldn't buy the stock
they were protecting the hedge funds
against the stock going up
so you couldn't and this is a big
controversy robin you couldn't execute
the buy
which is impo on wall street sometimes
you can't sell because of restrictions
but hey
anybody you want a stock boom you're you
got cash not leverage
boom you can buy it this is how the
casino
is rigged and it's written this is why
this transcends politics
because here you have this ape army of
just everyday americans and they're
teaching each other
they're teaching you so i mean brittany
avery was on she sounded like a traitor
goldman sachs woman's been in the stock
since january
she's talking about dips and shoulders
and you know and and they get naked
options and the la and the calls are
coming i mean i'm saying they go wow
this is not bad where'd she learn it she
learned it and they go online they teach
each other this is a community
and i'm telling you the charlie
gasparino
and all the wall street press the wall
street
seeking alpha has the the guy in the
short position who's sweating bullets
who writes the article
they are trying to force these guys to
sell for every host of reason to save
a citadel capital in the big highly
leveraged funds and this is why
it's one of the most it's applied
populism this is not people talking
about it
this is people doing and i'm not telling
the audience to go buy the stock
what i definitely would do is seek out
this community and find out more about
it you will learn
more about practical finance if you
don't know anything about the stock
market if you don't know anything about
economics you don't know anything about
finance
i think these people will teach you and
they will teach you what the reality is
and this is still and you come from the
occupy movement i mean this is the
this is the problem we've had since the
crash the problem we've had since the
crash in 2008
is that the one percent has gotten it's
insane because obama is the most
progressive president in history
the solution at the time was to
basically blow up the balance sheet of
the federal reserve
increase assets and let all people own
stocks and real estate
just they went from 880 billion in the
fed's balance sheet to 4.5 trillion
that money was infusing the system to
save the system
okay on the shoulders of the little guy
it was then paying for the bailouts it
was your taxes and also the negative
interest rate that when the interest
rates went to zero
zero interest rates kills the little guy
because you can never accumulate any
capital you don't get any interest on
your money market in your savings
account
it's destroyed this is why i say the
millennials are
nothing more than russian serfs they're
better educated you're in better shape
you have more access to information you
don't own anything
and you're not going to own anything and
today blackrock and blackstone are
buying up
every house in the country because of
zero interest rates they're going to get
the upside of the assets
you're going to pay the rent they keep
saying in the davos oh just be a runner
don't need to own anything
you'll have no skin in the game you'll
cont you'll just be a serve
that's going to be a search let's expand
on that you mentioned the seeking alpha
article i pulled it up
where it says an open letter to the apes
the stock market in reality
the original title the original title
was emotion may tell you to buy
reason will tell you to sell then once
you get all the way to the bottom as
steve mentioned i scrolled all the way
to the bottom and he says disclosure i
am we are short amc i wrote this article
myself and it expresses my own opinions
i'm not receiving compensation for it
other than seeking alpha i have no
business relationship with any company
whose stock is mentioned in this article
additional disclosure i have sold
amc calls i also own mgic mtg stock i
briefly mentioned
he's against the wall no first he sounds
like your father he's patting you on the
head and tell me about it then he gives
it then he's the voice of reason it
sounds so great
at the end of it all you want to do is
get out of the stock and you're right
and then you see
i gotta gather stock honey we gotta dump
it so this is
how the media tries to rip off little
guy this this
these people they come in they short of
stock and then once you know the apes
come back and they start saying hey
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
fight back
they you see all these articles come out
saying it's bad it's a bad idea don't
buy don't do it
cnbc doesn't even say the word naked
shorts but let me tell you something
else you mentioned blackrock
have you seen how many articles there
are right now saying millennials
don't buy a house or how many articles
say a recent poll says millennials hate
owning homes i don't like it
don't like it this is the the great
reset and and build back better they the
party of davos if you go to davos the
world can i perform that commercial it
starts up by
we don't need to own anything and we're
going to be happier right you will owe
nothing
you will be happy you will own nothing
and you will be happier and then all of
a sudden
here's the thing you're paying for it i
want to go back to the great alex jones
he said it information warfare what this
is there's three types of warfare
as the chinese teaches an unrestricted
warfare there's information warfare
that which is includes cyber but
propaganda there's there's um
economic warfare and there's kinetic
warfare
guns bombs everything like that and sun
tzu teaches you
hey i want to defeat them before we get
to kinetic foreign devils
what i want to do is information and
economic warfare
there is information in economic warfare
against the working class and middle
class
in the world today okay and this is why
this ape army's bringing it
that article is sophisticated
information warfare
psychologically it's very persuasive
both from an emotional point of view and
then at the end the reason point of view
you actually think your father your
your smart uncle is actually sitting
there going take the profit sell the
stock
sell the stock because the hedge funds
are jammed and then at the bottom
full disclosure oh i'm short that should
be at the top the disclosure should be
100 it's a rigged
casino the casino's rigged and their
friends make all the profits there's a
thing called arc archaegus
that was this uh family office the new
scam this family office
imploded a couple weeks ago making all
these trades gunning wong
but it was the banks there's 20 billion
dollars of losses
by morgan stanley by ubs
by no more securities billions and
billions of dollars okay
of all pension funds that's all the
deplorables money is wiped out reason
the latest scam they have the hedge
funds are virtually unregulated
the family offices are not on are unreal
there's zero regulation
this is all the super wealthy we've
created what the revolution in 1776 was
against was a landed aristocracy
in the united kingdom in england we have
created a global
aristocracy that's purpose in life is to
make sure the little guy never gets off
the mat and they will use
any type of information economic warfare
to do that
i want to go back something you
mentioned you mentioned that i came from
occupy and it was
and that's populous left and that's true
but
the people that i used to that i know
that uh i met during occupy
are authoritarian establishment left now
they're no longer populist libertarian
left they're
absolutely toe the line for the fbi
support the feds support the war
the most i tweeted something i posted on
facebook too
i said the the greatest
de-radicalization in the history of the
united states
the activists left who used to oppose
uh the federal government who are
supporting the hackers
who were the best weave the best free
speech people in the world
all of a sudden are posting in support
of the fbi the cia
are saying it's it's wrong to end the
wars because it'll create a power vacuum
and i'm like
wow i said this this is this uh woman i
know she was part of the hacker
community not necessarily big hacker
herself but she was friends with all of
them
she was very active during occupy and
she posted when the feds
raided giuliani's apartment in office
she was like yay and i said
incredible to see you finally
recognizing what was
wrong with your radicalism and
supporting the the fbi and the federal
government
the people of course you were protesting
quite literally for five years
and they don't understand one one person
who went to prison
for hacking said well better they use it
on my opponents than me and i was like
so you're an authoritarian who likes the
use of governmental force to shut down
your rivals
i was like bro didn't you protest that
exact thing weren't you one of the
people like
championing julian assange and
complaining about his
unlawful detainment or i shouldn't say
unlawful because they certainly claim it
is but the unethical
amoral detainment of julian assange now
all of a sudden you're happy
the federal government just goes and
does whatever they want
i don't know what happened to these
people no lord acton told us about it
power corrupts an absolute power
corrupts absolutely this is about power
that's right it's about power they now
have power
and and here's the thing think back to
the 60s and 70s
the the new york times the the
washington post the great investigative
reporting against the corruption in in
the cia
what was happening the cia in the fbi
that led to the church commission
all the checks and balances we kind of
had in congress the special committees
and the ability to have the the gang of
eight and review all this
this all came from essentially liberal
or left
center left or liberal the bastions of
liberal media in the 60s and 70s that
led to these investigations
that should have been done and had to be
done those
places today the new york times and the
washington post are
are the vanguard of protection of a
national security apparatus
i'm a foreign naval officer my daughter
went to west point you know we our whole
family my kid brother is here today as a
navy pilot all of a serve
we're the biggest guys are sitting there
going this apparatus is out of control
it's out of control against every
american i i love this
uh this i i wonder if
let me start over people have tried to
figure out what left and right means
in these in this day and age it
certainly meant something you know 20
years ago i guess maybe it didn't
uh during occupy it certainly did you
had the libertarian right you're the
libertarian left
wokeness came into occupy and really did
a number and destroying a lot of it
and i wonder if that was you know
intentional there's a comic we reference
where it's a
wealthy guy in a big office and there's
protesters saying occupy wall street
outside
he's on the phone and he goes introduce
identity politics that was one of the
big things that that really helped break
apart the libertarians who showed up to
occupy wall street they leave as soon as
this stuff pops into place
but i wonder if there is a big uh if if
the issue is
populist versus elitist or authoritarian
versus libertarian these are core
components
i think it's populist versus elitist in
in nationalist versus globalist
the nation state is still the best way
to to to to
to have your to have you not just your
values but to have your basic rights
right but how about uh the religious
framework as well right
so if you look at the woke which is a
very large component of the
establishment
their moral framework is fascistic they
believe there is no objective truth
there is only power
it was it was uh the late david graber
who was one of the
key organizers of occupy wall street who
actually said this
he tweeted out big element of the left
today is that this fascistic belief
there's no truth but power
and so you look at the the uh
judeo-christian moral framework
which is far from perfect but there's a
lot of aspects of it like
blackstone's formulation rooted in the
story of adam gamora i bring this up i
don't want to riff too much
on this but i think you know we try to
figure out what left and right means
and it's hard to know for sure but i do
think the biggest aspect might just be
will you be honest and fair with someone
and and and their rights to
individualism
or do you think those in power should
wield it against anyone who would oppose
them
well i think that that's what the
globalists i think the globalists are
totally materialistic and they prepare
that power corrupts and absolute power
corrupts absolutely and they
feel they have absolute power i think
everything on the cultural side are just
things a lot of things are just thrown
out there i'm still in economic and
financial power the
people that have that power actually
control things
right and they're trying to do other i
think one of the things that you saw
what mao did
and the bolsheviks did to try to break
the traditional
family the key is to break the family
right you see that here with a lot
what happened here i think with what i
call cultural marxism is still to have
these struggle sessions to try to break
the nuclear family and to break that
just like mao that was the whole thing
of the cultural revolution
was to break that same thing with the
bolshevik thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show
come back to this channel
youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you